this is on you girl all right i know you
can handle it you're a strong dancer
you're a strong performer i did not
expect to be the lead i thought it would
definitely be like kinley again but now
having her be behind me
is weird these are your little alien
costumes if i have seven of these around
me
it'll make a big skirt so the judges are
going to think that the lead is just
standing there wearing a costume with a
skirt you all are going to be her skirt
all of a sudden the skirt will start to
move so then when you come open the
judges are like oh my god i thought that
was part of the prop it's like the kids
are in there it's a big task for
everybody this week not only does kaya
have to be perfect on stage because
she's the lead but every other kid in
this group does they're pulling off the
illusion
they're doing the job of creating the
magic skirt they have to be perfect too
this dance there's a deeper meaning than
just being an alien sometimes you can
feel like you don't fit in you can feel
like you don't belong so that's kind of
what i mean by an alien
i've been an outsider on everything for
forever everybody in a way is an
outsider whether you're part of the
lgbtq community possibly your race
possibly your weight i'm gay
i've learned to be comfortable with it
that's what this dance is it's when
you're in a world but not a world that's
exactly meant for you but you're fitting
into it and that is cool
all right let's go kaya come here be in
the middle
bella and leah throughout potatum
[Applause]
[Music]
power
[Music]
so what's going on the lining the feet
can't fit in they're too tight jess and
i did kinley so hers is already done in
there
i don't know if setup is the right word
but i think that in the end on saturday
it's going to get down to which girl led
their dance to success kai was in the
bottom bottom last week last week yeah
so to go from the bottom to the lead
that makes when there were other kids
that were
pretty
i'm just glad my kid's not blonde
[Applause]
[Music]
you